addicts don't care about other people
addicts don't give a [ __ ] about
um and just to clarify anyone listening
and it's not a competition i'm not a
drug addict i'm not a i'm not a um
alcoholic i'm a sex addict a gambling
addict
recovering
food addict alcohol you know workaholic
all the process addictions you know
shopping
sex food love
all those things and like the the final
ones that i'm struggling with
are
food
and work
me too right like i mean when i met
stevo this is my first conversation he
comes into my house i'm you know the
korea house and i'm and i'm painting him
for the show and he's like bro i'm
skyjacking he's like he's like i don't i
don't he's like he's like explaining to
me i don't ever watch porn again i don't
watch porn anymore i'm like
tell me how you did it and then in the
next breath he goes so i'm watching porn
as i'm jerking out off out and i go wait
what he goes yeah i was trying to come
right as i pulled the parachute and and
and i had to watch porn i go
and it's what i say all the time and
it's the it's our like loophole
it's for work but it was for work right
for guys like us that turned our hobbies
into our careers
it's like oh i'm gonna do the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that's not okay
but it's for work yeah right
legit it is the only time i watched porn
in in years
i mean no judging bro by the way i'm
just saying like and i'm also a drug
addict and i did the riding the bicycle
thing with the general anesthesia drug
yeah you know that's like taking drugs
for work that was even more scary that's
like david's saying like okay i'm gonna
start painting prostitutes that i [ __ ]
while i [ __ ] them
but but i did do that did you really
yeah there was so many things that i did
in my addiction that i didn't want to do
but content oh this is gonna be my book
later yeah wow like this is gonna this
is gonna be in the documentary this is
gonna be you know everything is gonna be
a dope story for when i get to wild ride
one day you know with the blue lighting
in the back and so when i say addicts
don't give a [ __ ] i mean
they just want what they want they don't
think about like oh i'm going to kill
myself or i'm going to overdose they
don't think about how that's going to
affect their family their families
families like all the people around them
it's just like this behavior is just
like a tornado just ripping through
and so
i'm like
oh i'm horny i wanna have sex right now
i'm gonna get a prostitute she comes
she's like a supermodel that's doing
this on the side i'm like oh she's not
like a sex traffic worker you know and
there's no consideration of her trauma
of where she's from how she and it's
just like i want what i want right now
and she's she's
she's selling her body and i'm willing
to buy it so we're adults and we're you
know it's all good so
i don't see the problem there you know
and that's just my life i was like
everyone's an adult everyone's making
their decisions good and bad and so
um when i say that broke me that's what
i'm talking about it just it just like i
i went to i i was doing an s program too
and uh when i went through my inventory
yeah my sponsor at the time owned a uh a
women's battered shelter
so i i went there and like you know i
put in hours you know yeah for each
per number on the list that i couldn't
make amends to or whatever
and i was there for a while and uh you
know
finally got to know some of the girls
and they're like you know what are you
what are you doing here and they all
crowded around and i was like you know
i'm making amends for like i was an
[ __ ] to women and this and that
that [ __ ] me up because that's like me
as i'm telling them why i'm there
there's like little girls around them
and i'm just like looking at all these
girls like dude like [ __ ] yeah it was
heavy but this is how change happens
right yeah so
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]